meine Damen und Herren hören Sie eine
Ansprache des klicksum-moderators
Christoph krachten
erstens dauert es manchmal länger und
zweitens als man denkt Sarah Connor ist
so ein Fall wir haben echt alle Hebel in
Bewegung gesetzt es gibt sogar hier zu
sehen eine webinitiative die sich dafür
eingesetzt hat dass Sarah Connor zu
klicksum kommt und jetzt ist es der Fall
juhu ähm und natürlich dann wieder der
Zeitpunkt der richtige damit ihr Fragen
an sie stellt am besten als Videoantwort
wie immer und seid kreativ verfasst euch
kurz eine Frage und so weiter und guckt
das FAQ lest den Infotext unter dem
Video und dann steht der Beantwortung
eurer Frage durch Sarah Connor
eigentlich nichts also viel Erfolg